le procès civil mahorais ti l'occasion
cette semaine de mettre en cause le
comportement de nombreux acteurs dans la
sphère grégory après le juge les
gendarmes les journalistes les médecins
légistes
les policiers s'étaient aujourd'hui
isabelle steiss eric de lannion le
commissaire corradi se serait bien passé
d'être la vedette du jour
il a encore le sourire mais bientôt
c'est avec arrogance que celui qui
dirige l enquête à la pj de nancy sur la
mort de grégory va répondre à des
accusations gravissimes
selon les termes du président guysen si
vous êtes là aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on vous a accusé d'avoir mis au
domicile des villemin de fausses
cordelette comme celle qui ligotaient
grégory pour accabler la mer la réponse
est sèche
ce ne sont que des accusations de
journalistes on aurait pu en rester là
si à la barre il n'y avait des témoins
pour jeter le trouble ainsi martial
david il a déménagé la maison des
villemin juste avant la perquisition
on a balayé nettoyer il restait quelques
bricoles mais pas de cordelettes itil
pourtant des cordelettes ont bien été
saisi et mis sous scellés l'une d'elle
entourée un tuyau d'arrosage déposé chez
la voisine madame villiers le sait les
portent sa signature je n'ai jamais rien
signé affirme-t-elle aujourd'hui de la
cordelette identique genre jacob en
avait chez lui pour attacher ses tuiles
ya un jour dit il les policiers m'ont
pris des morceaux le commissaire corradi
conteste cette cordelette dit il on en a
même pas trouver chez les commerçants
mais c'est faux rétorque jean jacob
on en trouve partout c'est pas une
pelote de ficelle fabriqués spécialement
pour moi parole de policiers contre
parole de témoins si la confrontation
d'aujourd'hui n'a pas permis d'étayer
les accusations contre le commissaire
corradi et son équipe
elle a en tout cas mis en évidence des
méthodes peu rigoureuse dans la manière
de conduire une enquête concernant ces
cordelettes cordelettes qui ont pourtant
pesé bien lourd par la suite dans
l'inculpation de christine villemin